hey you guys it's time for another movie
review now just like the last regular
episode of 13 o'clock this is going to
be just me because Tom is still out of
town I'm recording this on Wednesday I'm
going to put it up on Friday now he
should be back in town Friday night so
the night that this comes up so from now
on he should be back on the show but you
know he's just been gone and he's been
taking care of his family stuff and
everything like that
and I really really appreciate everybody
that has sent me messages and commented
on the YouTube videos with their best
wishes about his dad and stuff like that
his dad has had the surgery it went fine
there you know just waiting to see what
the recovery process is going to be like
and everything like that but it seems
like the worst of it has passed so we'll
see how it goes and like I said Tom will
be back on Friday night so from now on
that he should be back on the show in
the ensuing episodes so since Tom is not
here I decided to do a movie review on
actually one of my favorite movies of
all time but one that Tom is actually
not seen but he's generally not crazy
about David Lynch movies in general so I
decided well I'll just put this one in
the can while he's not here and then I
don't have to make him watch it he'll be
like that's a little stupid you know and
I made it won't be like that so I'm
actually going to do Mulholland Drive
from 2001 now not only is this easily my
favorite David Lynch movie it's also in
my top 10 favorite movies ever and
apparently I'm not the only one with
that opinion it came out when it came
out in 2001 and actually premiered at
the Cannes Film Festival and David Lynch
won the Best Director prize that year
and subsequently Mulholland Drive has
gone on to win numerous numerous
accolades tons and tons of different
film magazines and film critics and
stuff like that have ranked Mulholland
Drive as you know the best movie of the
2000s and it's ended up on lots and lots
of critics like best movies ever list
and stuff like that even though it does
have its detractors like all David Lynch
movies do because you know surrealism in
film is just one of those things that
you like it or you think it's a bunch of
[ __ ] you know so where you stand on
that it's I'm not making a judgment or
anything like that I tend to really like
it I think probably the most common
criticism that people leveled at
Mulholland Drive and David Lynch movies
in general is that it doesn't make any
sense and all this other stuff now I'm
here to argue with you that this movie
absolutely does make sense but you have
to see it a couple of times it's really
it operates on a lot of subtext and
symbolism and things like that you
really have to be paying attention and
really you don't know what's going on
for the first three quarters of the
movie until you see the last quarter of
the movie at which point you should
probably start over and watch it all
over again and then you'll be like oh
okay now I understand so I'm gonna get
into that I'm gonna recommend right here
cuz I'm a total dork about this movie
and I'm like not even get ashamed of
that so there is a site that is just
called Mulholland Drive dotnet I think
yeah Mulholland Drive dotnet with a dash
in between Mulholland Drive and it is
like the world's most obsessive website
about Mulholland Drive it has this huge
huge essay by Alan Shaw which I'm gonna
be referring to a lot because I think he
really kind of nailed that everything in
this movie and it's it's super super
long and it's super detailed so you know
I'm only going to get into a little bit
of it but if you're really really
interested in this movie or you really
love this movie as much as I do then I
would recommend going to the site and
read it so it's a long read but it's
totally worth it and I think he totally
nailed it but there's also tons of links
to like reddit threads and stuff like
that with other people's theories and
stuff like that because Mulholland Drive
is a movie that's kind of open to
interpretation in general though I think
the narrative structure of it is pretty
cut-and-dried within that structure I
think there's like little details that
might be different or you can have your
own theories about and stuff like that
but overall I think it's a pretty
straightforward narrative now it's
actually interesting to me
this movie came out as brilliant as it
came out because I don't know if a lot
of you know this but it was actually
intended to be a television series but a
la Twin Peaks act so actually David
Lynch wrote and shot scenes for the
pilot in 1999 and he pitched it to ABC
executives they had actually asked him
to do it because they like twin peaks'
and they're like okay we'll do another
thing like that so this actually started
as a TV series now after the executives
saw the rough cuts or saw the pilot or
whatever they're like no we don't like
that it's too weird which I thought was
strange because it's like it's David
Lynch for chrissake what did you expect
so they didn't like it so I guess David
Lynch was kind of bummed out he's like
well I like this idea and stuff like
that so he decided to shoot extra stuff
and kind of close in the narrative and
make it a feature film which was
released in 2001 now so I've seen some
critics of this film argue that well you
can really tell that this was supposed
to be a TV series because there were all
these like unrelated plot threads that
weren't resolved or there was like all
these scenes with characters that you
didn't see again and stuff like that and
you know obviously he was intending to
finish up that storyline and he never
got to it because he didn't get to do
the series but I would actually argue
that that is incorrect I don't think
there's anything in this movie that
wasn't really resolved I know that when
you're watching it the first time
especially the first three quarters of
it there are a lot of scenes that
feature characters that don't really
turn up again or only turn up very
briefly like at the end and they seem to
not have anything to do with the main
plot but actually the more times you
watch it the more you understand how
everything interlocks and how everything
fits together so I don't think that he
left anything hanging or anything like
that and I'm gonna talk about that a
little bit too now another interesting
thing too since I mentioned Twin Peaks
evidently this series initially the
initial idea for it was it was supposed
to be a spin-off series about Audrey
Horne the character that sherilyn fenn
played on twin
this was gonna be about her like later
on I guess in her life or whatever
that's what she says anyway so that's
kind of where they're going with it now
it's kind of hard to classify um as most
of his movies are it's kind of a
psychological thriller kind of a noir
mystery type of thing but it also has a
lot of really surreal elements it has a
lot of dark comedy elements now what I'm
gonna do I think because this is I've
been waiting to do this one for such a
long time and it's like so complex and I
have like all these zillion ideas like
racing around in my head so so I
apologize if this is like a little
disjointed or goes off on tangents or
whatever because this is like a huge
topic and I've read and thought a lot
about this so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna give you like a layout of what the
plot seems to be then I'll kind of
explain to like go back and explain like
what's actually going on so on the
surface this movie appears to be about a
dark haired woman who is being driven
somewhere in a limousine and apparently
she is going to be she's in the
limousine with these two guys in the
front seat and they're going to kill her
like him she has a hit out on her now
before this happens these teenagers in
who were like drag racing coming the
other way smash into the limousine
there's a huge crash presumably everyone
is killed except for her now she crawls
out of the wreckage and she's you know
obviously disoriented and kind of hurt
and stuff like that but she manages to
run away from the scene of the accident
now it turns out we don't find out till
later but she has amnesia she has no
idea who she is she doesn't know where
she was going what she was doing why
somebody was trying to kill her anything
like that so she ends up hiding in an
apartment that is kind of left open
because this woman is going out of town
like you can see her door open and like
the cab drivers bringing all her luggage
out and stuff like that so it's obvious
she's going to be gone a long time so
while the mover is going in and out this
dark haired woman sneaks into the
apartment it kind of hides in there so
she has a place to stay now it turns out
that this apartment belongs to a woman
we only know his aunt Ruth and Aunt Ruth
has given Bernice
Betty who we are introduced to in a
little while she's played by Naomi Watts
she's given her some money and given her
this apartment to stay in while she's
gone so she can come to LA and be a big
star like cuz that's what her dream is
so when Betty arrives in LA and arrives
at the apartment she meets this
mysterious glamorous stranger and you
know as they discuss things and it comes
to pass and everything like that she
says she doesn't remember who she is and
stuff like that all she has on her she
has she's wearing like a black party
dress and she has a purse and
importantly inside the purse there's no
ID or anything like that all that is in
the purse is a [ __ ] ton of money in cash
and a blue key now the woman who takes
the name Rita from a poster for the
movie Gilda which had Rita Hayworth in
it that's on the aunt's apartment wall
so she suspects that she is in some kind
of trouble or that people are after her
or something like that now her and Betty
strike up a friendship which eventually
turns into a sexual relationship and the
main part of the narrative is the two of
them trying to figure out Rita's real
identity and what this money is and what
this key is and stuff like that
now as this narrative goes on there are
also some seemingly unrelated interludes
the other main part of this involves a
director a film director named Adam
Kesher and he is evidently being forced
by what appears to be the mob to replace
the lead actress in the movie that he's
working on with an actress of their
choosing so he's seen in a meeting with
these two like mobbed up dudes and
they're just like did they give him this
picture and they say you know this is
the girl and you have to put her in the
movie and at first he flips out and he
doesn't want to do it this is his movie
and you know how dare they tell him what
to do and stuff like that and so you
kind of follow Adam Kesher as he has
this just ridiculously horrible day like
because the mobsters tell him you have
to put this girl in the movie and he
says no I'm not going to do it it's my
movie he goes and he
sucks up their limousine the to mobster
brothers then he goes back to his house
because he's so pissed off and he finds
his wife in bed with the pool man gene
clean which I kind of love and his wife
kicks him out of his own house because
he's the [ __ ] evidently and you know
he's got pink paint all over Mallis
other stuff it's just all this crazy
[ __ ] happens so then later on it turns
out that because of the [ __ ] he did with
the mobsters they have somehow been able
to cut off all his money so he is broke
so he ends up staying at this kind of
flophouse hotel that's run by this guy
named cookie and all this other kind of
stuff so that stuff is going on along
with the Betty and Rita trying to find
out Rita's identity thing now there are
also a couple of other scenes in there
that really seem like they don't belong
one of these is a hitman who turns up in
this office we don't know who he is we
don't know who the guy he's talking to
is and they're just talking and kind of
joking around and stuff like that and
the Hitman shoots him and then it turns
out that he accidentally shot through
the wall and he shot this other woman in
the next apartment through the wall like
in her so she's big that woman and so he
has to go over there and kill her and
then someone else sees it and he has to
kill them too and like it's just this
farcical kind of scene like this
bumbling hitman now evidently the whole
we're not really sure what his mission
is but he was evidently just supposed to
kill the first guy that was sitting at
the desk and steal this black book now
we don't really know what's in the black
book or why he needed it or anything
like that so there's that scene there's
also some scenes with the gangsters and
with this mysterious guy named mr. rope
who's played by the little-person actor
that also played the little person from
the Red Room in Twin Peaks he doesn't
move and he only has like two lines he's
in he's looks like he's like strapped in
this wooden chair and they actually
built him like normal size like
prosthetic arms so it would make his
head look really small because you know
how David Lynch loves to make everything
look grotesque and stuff like that and
this guy is just like behind glass and
people only talk to him like through an
intercom no one
really says who this is but he's
supposed to be like the guy that's
behind it all or something like that
now the other scene that I want to talk
about I'm gonna get more into this later
because this scene here even though it
involves characters that seemingly don't
have anything else to do with the plot
I think this scene is kind of is almost
like the movies mission statement or
like like an abstract of a scientific
paper it's kind of like um the fulcrum
of the entire thing we're kind of like
the key that explains it all and the
scene I'm talking about is the very
famous Winkies diner scene between the
two guys who are talking about one of
the guys is telling the other guy about
a dream Eze had about this horrible
monster behind the diner and all this
other stuff so I'm gonna get into that a
little bit later because like I said I
think that's kind of important so all
this stuff is going on at the beginning
now there's a scene near the end of this
first part where Rita and Betty go to a
theater called Club Silencio and while
they're in there it's like this really
bizarre show about like a guy coming out
and saying you know there's no band
everything's an illusion and all this
other stuff and after that performance
Betty opens her handbag and there's a
blue box in there that seems to match
the blue key that Rita had so now when
they get back to the apartment they
decide they're gonna open this blue box
with the blue key but when that happens
they get the blue key they get the blue
box in the room she puts it down on the
bed and then suddenly she's gone she
disappears and Rita is like looking for
and doesn't know where she went now Rita
opens the blue box with the blue key and
is seemingly sucked into it there's just
blackness now after this part this is
where the final fourth of the movie
begins and I think people like I said if
you don't know what's going on in this
this is gonna seem very confusing to you
because after the whole thing with the
blue box opening after that point you
see the same actors but now their names
are all switched like their identities
are all switched and all this different
[ __ ] is going on so here's where I'm
going to kind of explain what's going on
okay now
one of the best analogues sambhal
holland drives to understand its
narrative structure is the Wizard of Oz
now David Lynch
has kind of an affinity with Wizard of
Oz he's used actually in wild at heart
from 1990 he used a lot of Wizard of Oz
imagery like blatantly Laura Dern's mom
shows up as the Wicked Witch of the West
at one point well on the bicycle on
everything and at the end of it I think
it's Sheryl Lee she's playing Glinda the
Good Witch and she comes down in a
bubble like telling sailor who's
Nicholas Cage that he should go back to
Lula and all this other kind of stuff so
he has a thing for that movie and has
used imagery from it in a lot of his
other movies now this one The Wizard of
Oz connection I think is less obvious
but the overarching structure of the
movie is very very similar to The Wizard
of Oz because the final fourth of the
movie represents the real life of the
character Diane Selwyn played by Naomi
Watts now she has been seen as Betty in
the first part of the movie so what
we're seeing now okay I'm gonna say
right here that some people will argue
okay so the first three quarters of this
is a dream or a fantasy vision of Diane
sulwon's
now some people have argued that the
last part of it is also a dream or you
know it's a dream within a dream but for
whatever it's not really that important
now I would argue that the last fourth
of the movie is not necessarily
objective reality because we're still
seeing things through Diane's cell one's
perceptions so you know though I think
it's kind of sort of reality or sort of
what really happened it's probably
colored by her own perceptions and her
own mental state and things like that
but that's not really here or there in
general the last part of the movie is
real life the first three quarters of
the movie is a dream or a fantasy that
she has constructed in order to deal
with something terrible that she has
done like she's trying to work it out in
her mind now like I said this is very
similar to The Wizard of Oz because in
The Wizard
Oz Dorothy is very unhappy and she
thinks somebody loves her and miss Gulch
is gonna kill her dog and all this other
kind of stuff so she decides to run away
and then during the tornado she gets
knocked out she falls asleep and she has
this vivid fantasy where she recasts
people from her real life into her dream
but they're all aspects of her persona
and she's trying to work out she's
trying to work out her own like
emotional issues by using these other
people in these other roles so
Mulholland Drive is very similar so at
the end of the movie in the last part of
the movie we see the character we've
known as Betty we now find out is Diane
Selwyn now Diane Selwyn has come to LA
and unlike in the first part of the
movie her career hasn't been going so
well she hasn't really been getting much
work there is implications that she may
have had to work as a prostitute to make
ends meet things of that nature like a
lot of this is like I said you're not
gonna get this from the first reading of
the film necessarily because a lot of
this is in the subtext and in the
details and in the symbolism and
references to other movies that David
Lynch has added and things like that but
the implication being that she came here
it's not going so well she's kind of
living in sort of a crappy apartment and
at some point she got into a
relationship with the glamorous
dark-haired actress who in her fantasy
was an amnesiac and was named Rita but
in real life is named Camilla runes
which is actually the name of a blond
woman in her fantasy that she saw
auditioning for another role and that
will kind of come into play later too
now her and Camilla got into a
relationship and perhaps lived together
at some point and Diane was way more
into Camilla than Camilla was into her
now Camilla is very foxy very vampy you
know she and she ends up getting a lot
more parts and a lot better person Diane
is getting and the implication is that
she might have been sleeping around to
get them or was willing to do so or at
least that's how Diane perceived it so
Rita star is rising now or Camilla
rather now Camilla
gets a role in a big film and she kind
of throws Dianna bone and gives her like
a little extra or like a background roll
or something like that now on this film
she meets Adam Kesher the director who
we saw in the beginning of the movie and
those two start a relationship so at
some point there is a conflict where
Diane wants to desperately wants to hang
on to Camilla but Camilla does not
really love her and does not want to
hang around she wants to go marry Adam
and you know get up in all the Hollywood
starlet business and everything like
that so she breaks up with Diane now
Diane does not take this too well
obviously because she has become
obsessed with come with Camilla and
actually in a way kind of wants to be
her so later on there's actually a party
now after the breakup
Camilla calls Diane and says you know oh
come to this party I want you to come
now Diane perhaps naively thinks this is
because Camilla is sorry and wants to
get back with her and stuff like that
now Camilla sends her sends a car says a
limousine to pick Diane up now Diane
gets in the limousine and she's going up
to a house on Mulholland Drive now this
is interesting because this scene here
at the end of the movie is an analogue
to the scene at the very beginning of
the movie where quote/unquote Rita was
in the limousine she got stopped the
Hitman turned around and turned a gun on
her she said you know we don't stop here
what's going on and then there was a big
car accident so in this iteration Diane
is being driven up to the party of which
is on Mulholland Drive and the car stops
and she says the same thing that Rita
said at the beginning she says what's
you know what are you doing we don't
stop here but this time it turns out
that Camilla has come down like this
secret path from the house and she takes
her by the hand and it's all magical and
everything like that yeah we're gonna go
up to the party and it's gonna be
wonderful and everything like that
except then when she gets to the party
Camilla kind of humiliates her in front
of everybody
now like I said we're probably seeing
this through Diane's perception so I'm
not sure how much of this can be trusted
like I'm not sure how cruel Camilla
actually is because if this is
how it happened an objective reality
quote-unquote then Camilla's a [ __ ]
I'm sorry she's just a horrible horrible
content woman because who would do this
I mean she invites this woman that she
once had a relationship to the party
kind of hinting oh maybe we'll get back
together maybe wah wah all this kind of
stuff and then she brings the girl back
to the party and then proceeds to ignore
her announces her engagement to Adam max
on this other girl who is the same girl
that Diane cast as Camilla Rhodes in her
dream at the beginning of the movie and
basically just makes her feel like [ __ ]
so this is like the last straw right and
Diane is not in the best mental state
now anyway you know now because the
break-up and everything like that but
also because you know her dreams of
Hollywood stardom are really not working
out the way she thought they would so
after the party which is like her final
humiliation she goes to a hitman who
implication being that this is her pimp
or someone that's associated with her
pimp because in the dream at the
beginning or in the first portion of the
movie the dream portion of the movie
he's seen with a hooker and the
implication being that he's her pimp and
the hooker is not Naomi Watts but it
looks a lot like her like she has like
the short blonde hair and she has like a
shirt a same shirt that um Diane / Betty
wears later on so the implication being
that she's in her dreams she was like
recasting that role that she did as
someone else so she's sitting at Winkies
diner in the same booth as the two guys
from the beginning talking about the
monster behind the diner and she wants
to hire a hit man to kill Camilla so
this so that does eventually come to
pass now the blue key is the hit man
shows her the blue key and he says when
it's done you'll find this in the place
I said okay so the blue key is symbolic
of the knowledge that Camilla is dead
and that Diane was responsible for her
death because she paid the hit man this
is also why Camilla's purse Camilla /
Rita's purse in the dream
the film was filled with money and had a
blue key in it because that was the
knowledge you know that she had hired a
hit man to kill Camila so the hit does
go through or we presume because Diane
is seen in her shitty apartment and the
blue key is on her coffee table as if
she has picked it up so from that point
forward she just starts to have a
complete mental breakdown and stuff like
that now the final portion of the film
like I said kind of represents reality
it's done almost kind of like not really
in the present but it's done mostly in
flashback so you can see what led up to
this particular thing now the point at
which she's having the dream is probably
after she has gotten the key because the
dream seems to be her trying to come to
terms with the guilt of what she's done
and this is why I think the scene and
Winkies diner is probably the most
important one in the movie in the sense
that it's common it's almost making like
a meta statement about the movie as a
whole so I'm gonna talk a little bit
about the same which is actually one of
the creepiest scenes in film ever and I
can't and I don't even know why it's
just the way it's shot like the sound
behind it you know it's just there's
just something just really really skinny
crawling about it and David Lynch is
really really good at that at that type
of uncanny like you know bringing up
that kind of uncanny feeling so in this
scene we're seeing a guy named herb I
don't think he's named in the movie but
I'm pretty sure that's what his name is
and this other guy named Dan now we
don't know what the relationship between
them is it seems like herb is Dan's
therapist so I'm kind of imagining and
like I said the first part of the movie
you have to understand that none of
these people are that way in real life
you're only seeing Diane's perception of
them or Diane's recasting of them
because this is a whole dream or vision
that she came up with in her mind so
even though these people might exist in
reality you're not seeing them as they
really are you're only seeing them as
she perceives them so I'm guessing that
the herb guy either represents her
therapist or actually is her therapist
so Dan who is apparently the patient so
I'm gay
saying that Dan represents Diane dan and
Diane very similar name so I'm guessing
that that's what that represents now he
is telling her that he wanted to come to
this particular Winkies diner which is
on Sunset Boulevard and that's another
another lot of references that David
Lynch makes in this movie he makes a ton
of reference to references to Sunset
Boulevard it's really fun to actually
pick up all the movie references the
references to other movies that he makes
in this he really makes them to Sunset
Boulevard in marburg Mann's persona
there's a bunch of other stuff in there
but you know like I said a lot of that's
on the website and you can look that up
if you want I won't go too much into it
but so Dan says well he wanted to come
to this particular Winkies because he
had a dream about it he had two dreams
about it actually
he said no look just like this on the
inside but it wasn't day and it wasn't
night it was like a half night so we're
already you know it this scene actually
comes very very early in the movie it's
only about five or ten minutes into the
movie and I think if I'm remembering it
correctly I just watched the film a
couple of days ago again I think it
actually comes before Betty is even
introduced so you know like I said this
is kind of like the mission statement of
the film and already he's saying I've
had two dreams about this place it was
like half night things like that so
you're already getting a hint that what
you're seeing isn't real um you know or
it's a dreamer fantasy or whatever and
he says that I mean essentially he says
he's saying to the therapist he says
you're in both dreams you're scared
he says then I realize that there's a
man behind the wall he's behind the wall
behind the diner he's the one who's
doing it but he doesn't say what it is
or anything like that the therapist is
like so you wanted to come here to make
sure that that guy wasn't behind there
because he says the face is horrible and
I hope I never see it outside of a dream
and it's been freaking him out I guess
so he has come to this particular diner
to kind of check and see if this
horrible beast is behind the diner the
man who's doing it I can see him through
the wall he says so the therapist is
like okay well let's go check now so
they go and check behind the diner and
it will surprise no one to discover the
there is a very horrible looking person
behind the diner
at which point dan either faints or dies
it actually kind of looks like he dies
because it looks like herb is like
calling his name and like checking his
pulse in and he's like oh my God he's
dead or something like that it doesn't
really matter but essentially you're
seeing this it's a bum really a hobo
that lives behind the diner now I have
seen this hobo this hobo is symbolic now
the bum behind Winkies diner I've seen
it I've seen it said that it symbolizes
failure and maybe in part but I don't
think that's entirely accurate what the
bum behind the diner represents is the
parts of Diane that made her kill kamila
so it's like it's the deepest darkest
part of herself the part she doesn't
want anyone to know exists so it
represents her own evil the reason why
the bomb is behind the diner I think is
because in real life when Diane ordered
the hit on Camilla and the Hitman said
I'll leave this blue key where I told
you I think the place where he left it
was behind Winkies diner because they
set up the hit in that same Winkies
diner so I'm imagining that he left the
blue key behind the diner so that's why
I think the bomb lives back there and
that's why I think that in Diane's dream
at the beginning she sees this man and
he's terrified of something that's
behind the diner because that was the
whole thing she knew that when she went
behind the diner and found that blue key
that meant Camilla was dead so that was
the final thing that she didn't want to
face and when Dan faced it in the
fantasy portion of the film he fainted
her drop dead he couldn't deal with it
so it seems like the first part of the
movie the entire first part of the movie
is not only Diane trying to not exactly
trying to justify what she did I think
there is a little bit of that but I
think she's trying to come to terms with
it trying to almost absolve herself
maybe because there's a lot of things
going on in the fantasy portion of the
film that kind of speaks to her mental
state it's
it's it's fascinating that she recasts
herself as Betty Betty Elms is the name
of the character who is kind of this
overly naive chipper stars in her eyes
kind of like golly gee whiz type of
character because in real life she is
Diana's not like that at all
so I think she's trying to portray
herself as this wide-eyed naive starlet
who's come to the magical land of Los
Angeles and is going to be a big star
and everything like that now the reason
that she recasts her real girlfriend who
she had killed Camilla Rhodes the reason
she recast her as quote-unquote Rita a
girl who has amnesia is because she
still loves Camila but there are a lot
of things about her that she doesn't
love so the fact that she makes Rita in
her dream not have not know what her
identity is and be dependent on Betty
means that she gets to have sex with
Camila she gets to have a relationship
with Camila without all the bad stuff
because Rita in the dream is very meek
and very she's nothing like the real
Camila so I think she's trying to
separate the two parts out of it this is
what she wanted Camila to be like but
Camila was not like that so she kind of
recast her as amnesiac like oh it's a
blank slate you know now I can mold her
any way I want to mold her so that's
what was going on there and the
interesting thing too about in her dream
she dreams about Adam Kesher who's a
real person and he's identity has not
changed from the fantasy portion to the
reality portion but in the fantasy
portion not only does she make him have
like a horribly shitty day like he loses
control of his movie and he gets beat up
by gangsters and he gets his wife leaves
him is like sleeping with the poolman
and all this other kind of stuff it's
because she wants to punish him because
he was she perceives that he was the one
that took Camila away from her because
they were going to get married so she's
punishing him
her dream and another thing that she
does too in this in the dream is that
she adds the characters of the gangsters
and them having control of the movie and
stuff like that almost like she's trying
to justify why she didn't get movie
roles in her real life because you know
there's all these power brokers and
gangsters were controlling the thing and
they didn't want her so that's probably
why they you know they had to cast this
other woman you know they were forced to
and all this other kind of stuff so
she's trying to kind of come to terms
with the fact that she's like oh well I
didn't get parts not because I'm not a
good actress it's because there were all
these like machinations like behind the
scenes like all these gangsters
controlling the stuff and they wanted
this other chicken so it's not my fault
so the whole for her spore ssin of the
movie is her just trying to recast her
entire life and particularly the murder
of Camila almost like not really trying
to sweep it under the rug but trying to
just reestablish what happened like I
said to kind of a labeling for herself
in a way but the thing about it though
is that if you watch the fantasy portion
of the film as it goes on you can see
that her sleeping brain is trying to
give her hints about what she really did
so it keeps trying to intrude into this
fantasy world that she's tried to
construct you know first of all there's
the scene with herb and the man behind
the diner and stuff like that obviously
that's her brain saying hey behind the
diner that's the knowledge of what you
did and everything like that but she
casts it with different people so she
can keep it at arm's length and as they
go on like as Betty and Rita are doing
their investigation and they go to the
apartment of another person who's named
Diane Selwyn which is actually her name
so they go to this other and they find a
dead woman in the bed that's obviously
been there for a few days so this is
Diane's sleeping brain trying to come in
and say hey you know you're gonna kill
yourself as loads of which is what
happens at the end of this movie spoiler
alert I meant to put at the beginning of
this for you I'll put in the
descriptions you know this is going to
have like a really lot of spoiler
and also actually I would recommend that
you watch the movie before you listen to
this because otherwise I'm just gonna be
babbling and you will have no idea what
in the hell I'm talking about okay so I
should have said that at the beginning
but I'm saying it now anyway and like I
said I'll say in the description so you
can read it beforehand but yes boiler
alert so she does kill herself at the
end but her brain knows all of this
stuff knows what she did and so it keeps
trying to poke into her dreamlike chart
trying to get her to realize what she's
done and you know that so the same thing
happened with the whole scene in club
Silencio and all that other kind of
stuff so you know that's why you see in
that scene where all the where all the
performers it seems like they're really
performing especially Rebecca Del Rio is
in this and she does a really really
gorgeous acapella Spanish version of the
Roy Orbison song crying and it's right
it's beautiful
and so that's in there and it seems like
she's really singing like her if the
look on her face and she's very
passionate everything like that but then
near the end of the song she just kind
of like drops dead and the music keeps
going so the whole implication of the
theater scene is that everything is an
illusion so he's trying to he's not only
trying to I mean David Lynch is not only
trying to say you know it's a film so
it's all an illusion and he's kind of
making a meta statement there at you too
I think but he's also this is also
Diane's brain saying okay it's this is
the realization this is none of this
happened and she opens the person sees
the blue box which represents you know
with the key and everything that
represents the knowledge of what she did
that's inside the box which is why she
disappears when the blue box is opened
and reality comes back and intrudes
again now like I said that I could talk
about this for hours and hours but I
won't
I won't bore you or anything like that
but there is a ton a ton of other stuff
this movie I didn't even talk about the
character of the cowboy and who's really
kind of really an interesting character
who turns up a couple of times I didn't
say anything about a lot of the
background stuff like the color
symbolism the red lampshades the
painting of Beatrice enchi that's in the
background of the answer
apartment all the stuff about redheads
all the stuff about Aunt Ruth and where
she is and stuff like that but you know
this is our D this is already longer
than most mother maybe European such a
knew it would be because when I get
started on this I'll just kind of go out
but if you were really really interested
in this movie and like I said I hope
you've already seen it because otherwise
you won't know what the [ __ ] I'm talking
about but if you're really geeky about
this movie like I am and just and want
it explained like they will explain the
[ __ ] out of it then go to this site it's
Mulholland - Drive net it's just this
huge and particularly if you click on if
you go to the home page there's a link
for Alan Shaw's essay I'll link to it in
the description and it is just set aside
a few hours and just read everything I
was just like [ __ ] fascinating I've
read this entire site several several
times
as you can probably tell because I'm
super super into this movie it's one of
my favorite movies of all time and I
really love that because like I said a
lot of people you know I've met a lot of
people that don't like David Lynch
movies they don't like surrealism
there's like why can't they just be
straightforward why does it have to be
all this rigmarole why all this other
kind of stuff but I love [ __ ] like this
I mean I love the fact that this book
this movie is almost like a really
really complicated book it's like a
really complicated novel it's like the
more like you see it the first time and
you're just kind of like what like
everything things seems really
disjointed it's like why are these
people changing identities what the [ __ ]
is going on but the more times you see
it you just pick up like all these
little subtle thing all these subtext
and stuff like that and it's just so
it's so layered and there's just so much
going on in here you know that there's
just there's this whole storyline that's
going on beneath the surface and the
more times you see it and figure out all
his movie references and all his
symbolism and stuff like that it just
becomes a richer and richer experience
like every single time you see it and I
just love that I love movies that have
that have such repeat watch ability and
stuff like that you know I love all of
it all of his movies really except dune
which I don't love I mean we did a
review of that but that wasn't really
his fault I mean he wasn't really
working from his own stuff but um I
pretty much loved all his movies this is
this is
very similar similar kind of structure
to lost highway which I also really
loved although I think this is a massive
improvement on it but you can see that
this is one of his pet themes and stuff
like that now the movie that came out
after this one which actually I think it
was his last feature film was Inland
Empire and that had a similar kind of
thing
now Inland Empire I would not
necessarily recommend if you're not a
David Lynch fan because if you think
Mulholland Drive is inscrutable then you
there is no way you will think of it
let's fire out
it is the it is the lynches of all David
Lynch movies it's just it's like three
hours long and it's just I haven't even
fully figured it I think I kind of know
what's going on but not really but but
it has it's just it sucks you in though
even though you're not entirely sure
what's gonna some really really great
creepy scenes and stuff like that but
the same kind of thing applies with
Mulholland Drive I actually think even
though it does seem inscrutable on its
surface I actually think it's probably
one of his more accessible movies you
know along I guess blue velvet was
pretty straightforward while it hard was
pretty straightforward but this one
doesn't seem straightforward at first
but I think it does the more times you
see it so you know if you're into Lynch
or if you're into just weird movies in
general I would recommend it and like I
said if you're a dork about it like I am
then just go to this website and read
all this stuff because it's fascinating
like all the theories and stuff that
people have come up with some of them I
think are [ __ ] but or reaching but
um a lot of this there's a lot of really
good stuff in there and like I said the
Allen Shaw essay I really think he
pretty much nailed it there's a couple
little points where I think well I don't
know if I'd go that far but on the whole
I think he pretty much got it and and
all of the stuff all the little pieces
that he picks out of the movie and and
explains it's it's very well researched
and very well explained I think so I
think that'll do it for this episode
talking about one of my favorite movies
Mulholland Drive if you liked 13 o'clock
please remember to Like share subscribe
on all your social media and also check
out our patreon page which is
patreon.com slash
thirteen o'clock podcast if you'd like
to support the show if you don't want to
use patreon we also have a PayPal
account which you can access by going to
our blog at 13 o'clock podcast WordPress
com and there's a little link in the
sidebar
that goes to a PayPal account if you
would like to support this show that way
again thank you all very much for all
your support about Tom being away and
stuff like that he should be back the
same day that this movie review goes up
and he also really appreciates all the
love and support from everybody and so
he should be back for the next episode
so until next time bye